very pleased to say the shadow Health
and Social care Minister laborers Liz
Kendall is here this morning very good
morning to you and it is a mile away
from your brief but but given what we
are hearing about Russian spy ships what
we had yesterday about Russian cyber
attacks on infrastructure and what we
are seeing every day in Ukraine we
really need to be mindful of the risk
from Russia don't we we need to remain
absolutely Vigilant against Russia's
activities as you can see uh different
sorts of warfare whether that's more
traditional types in Ukraine or new
cyber attacks and we have to also remain
Vigilant against the cronies of Putin in
this country and elsewhere to show them
that they cannot profit from this
behavior that twin track approach proper
defense and those economic sanctions is
essential for the future but there is an
awful lot to talk about on on your brief
this morning and and your party has been
it's been spending the week looking at
the NHS today you've been looking at
cancer and I have to say some of the
statistics here are are not just deeply
concerning they are abysmal they are
abysmal um just walk us through what
you've discovered
well this is information we've been
given by hospitals themselves and what
we have found is that patients are
waiting up to six months to even see a
specialist doctor once they've been
referred by a chief these are these
origin references these absolutely and
we know that across the board more than
half a million patients had to wait more
than two weeks that's the Target to get
you a scene urgently more than half a
million weighted more than that last
year we're also seeing patients waiting
up to years to actually start and finish
their treatments the Target that you
should start your treatment within two
months has not been met since December
2015. so we know that kovitz had an
impact but this is a problem long before
and I mean I hope that neither you nor
your family have ever had this situation
but it is
frightening waiting to be diagnosed and
it is frightening waiting to start your
treatment terrified that the cancer has
spread so this is a serious problem
which needs a serious plan of action and
we've been talking about that action
plan from Labor's perspective today it
would be remiss of me as a journalist
not to not to say actually you I have a
very very someone very very close to me
has recently been through this whole
process and indeed had to go private
because of because of lack of revision
so I will state that right now but but
what is the solution to it I mean of
course oncology is not the only aspect
of the Health Service that had that has
massive waiting lists but there is the
necessity to get treatment as soon as
possible if you are to maximize the
chances of people actually surviving so
first of all you need the staff and we
have said we'll bring in the biggest
ever expansion of the NHS Workforce in
its history doubling the number of
medical school places 10 000 more nurses
because you can't get that care without
the staff but secondly you've also got
to have the beds and we know at the
moment that one in seven hospital beds
in the NHS have got an elderly patient
in them who doesn't need to be there if
they got the right care in the community
at home so you need that plan of action
more doctors have the beds that you need
to I would also argue there needs to be
real reform there a lot of people will
find they go in and out for lots of
different tests MRI scans and others and
actually what we need to do is bring
those teams together look at the patient
pathway try and get it also they get
your tests done on the same day
investment staff and reform that's the
key to getting these weights down it may
well be the key to getting the waiting
times done but what you're talking about
you know in terms of capacity within the
Health Service and talk of in terms of
social care itself I mean we are talking
about a decades-long project to sort of
to sort these things out well you can
make immediate progress for example if
you can get those elderly people out of
Hospital free up those beds but that
will only come if there is drastic
reform in the social care system more
capacity there better wages for careers
you take my point the government has
just spent 750 million pounds to try and
sort these delayed discharges as a
result of that there's only a couple of
hundred fewer patients in those beds
that's because they didn't get the home
care right so I think that their plan
failed to work we need a different
approach but I would say to you we do
need a long term plan I'm not claiming
that this would change overnight but
forgive me for reminding of people back
in 1997 we faced a very similar
situation when labor came into
government weights of 18 months or more
and we did actually bring them down to
18 weeks that is a huge change it won't
happen overnight but we can start making
a difference the other thing I would
just quickly say because this is
something I myself experiences it's so
so difficult to even get to see your GP
to get the referral in the first place
so we've got to get those face-to-face
appointments up and running quickly too
and I wonder if we can also attend to
what that which we're hearing from from
swella Bradman we're appear to stood
this up with the home office this
morning that that the judges will be
able to sorry that the ministers will be
able to direct judges to ignore uh
certain rulings that they will have the
power to deport migrants and that there
will not be the power to stop them
through the legal system what do you
make of that well you you will forgive
me for saying I will believe this when I
see it every single claim the government
has made about how they're going to stop
the boats and get the deportations has
not worked in fact the situation has got
worse more people coming over more money
being spent on hotels and accommodation
uh backlogs growing what I think is
happening here is the government is is
very good at getting the headlines it's
not good at delivering the plan and the
action we need to get this sorted out
okay but why then is secure stamina not
made stopping small boats one of his
five priorities
it's been absolutely clear we've got to
sort this problem out we've said that we
need to sort out the criminal Gans speed
up the applications process make sure
they're safe routes for people who are
genuinely fleeing War because you know
the British people do want to see
control of our borders but they are also
fair and open-minded for people who are
really suffering and fleeing War but
that's what we need completely but you
also understand why the British public
might not be entirely saying when with
for example convicted murderers
convicted sexual offenders remaining in
this country because it is judged that
the place to which they would be
returned would be too dangerous for them
I mean I I'm absolutely clear that the
criminal justice system has been broken
under this conservative government you
talk about those sorts of crimes why is
it that only two of every 100 rapes
is even charged why is it 346 days
the British public are not happy with
the fact that people who have been
convicted of offenses are as serious as
rape and murder are allowed to remain in
this country because judges decide that
the place to which we want to return
them is too dangerous rather than of
course that it is too dangerous for the
British public for those people I want
to see all dangerous criminals and
people convict convicted of rape and
murder properly dealt with people who
come to this country but also people
who've been born and brought up in this
country the criminal justice system
under the conservatives
is broken we have the longest Court rate
weight on record my own constituents not
getting their cases dealt with for
absolutely years that is the result of
13 years of this government Labor's got
a plan to put that right and I hope at
the local elections we'll get the chance
to send the message to this government I
will also find out that's kind of good
to see